hello everyone and welcome to a very
special fourth of July edition of
GameSpot of Thrones you might notice
we're in a slightly different location
the air conditioning in our studio is
not working so in the lovely breakout
area felt like we were like those those
Carl's that got burnt alive there yeah
it was um it was down postie it was
moist it was gross so we're out here I'm
Lucy joined as usual by Dave hello and
tomorrow you know so we thought we'd do
a little bit of a post-mortem on season
six cuz you know it's still fresh in our
in our minds and our hearts I know hard
yeah
also because you know I'm just sad it's
gone yep also spoilers but you know that
all up in here alright season six it's
over what were our favorite bits let's
start with those tomorrow I think for me
it was the the big moment for me was
Daenerys the unburnt she's been called
online vol 2 yeah mother of dragons
breaker of chains queen of the Andals
and Seven Kingdoms I'd like to add you
to my professional network but the last
two seasons most of season six and the
entirety of season five I'd say well
spent taking power away from her and so
like for for the last half of this this
season we finally got to see her
becoming Khaleesi once again and kind of
taken that back she spent all this time
freeing slaves and you know fighting
these oppressors and being a generally
good person and then she kind of hit a
wall at one point I was like well now
I'm gonna get kidnapped and now I'm
gonna get stuck with these Dothraki for
ages like what's going on it was almost
as if like she was moving too fast for
the rest of the story like everyone else
needed to get to a point where you know
they they were good for her to come over
and be like all right guys I'm gonna
sort this stuff out now but she went a
bit too far so they kind of had to leave
her in a kidnapped position for a little
while but she took care of business she
took out the you know Dothraki got her
dragons back on
and now is ready to roll again it's that
powerful feeling like everyone's okay
everyone online is like yes Khaleesi is
back cuz in the book when like Daenerys
is interim 'but just goes on forever
it's just satin marine like the whole
marriage stuff fighting the bloody
fighting pits yes I'm really glad she
got somewhere this year she's earned her
title of Khaleesi back again finally
all right so we enjoyed yeah I'm glad
Daenerys is you know finally open about
them hmm what else did you enjoy I like
to see Jon Snow abandoning his watch so
he's always been this character that
he's the one he's the people's champion
right everyone loves him all we've seen
of him is him getting trodden on non
stops like from put up here he's been
like stepped on from the outset like
he's referred to as the bastard
obviously Ned gave him a little bit of
respect but there was always this
undertone of like segregation with
everyone else even his brothers perhaps
maybe less her with aiya exactly yeah so
it's always been like and since then
it's been one thing often another for
him like bad wrap up bad he's gone to
the wall stuff didn't go well there then
he you know he had this very brief
period where he was happy where he met
Ygritte and that ended very poorly for
him but like now this moment was like
this triumphant moment where he's
finally seems like he's taking like his
own destiny into his own hand so the
first thing he did was he got killed it
was almost like an awakening for him he
needed to die to realize that I can't
rely on other people so he comes back
and he's like firstly Olly you little
[ __ ] I'm gonna hang you and it was
amazing because like they they kind of
he flirted with a little bit of like
emotion and kind of remorse at the idea
but it was very very fleeting like he
was like maybe it now
yep that's it and you could see he got a
bit of satisfaction out of killing Olly
and the people that betrayed him and
then he obviously throws off his cloak
ins like my watches over my watch is
ended I'm done and that was like yes
finally and since then he's kind of he's
had success after success right like not
unequivocal successes but still
successes he you know won the Battle of
Easter he's taken out one of the most
reviled characters in the entire series
right and that's kind of a big win for
him and for us he's like proved himself
to be king bastard
yeah there's nobody north and now
obviously yeah he's king in the north
get a chance
for really long awkward amount of time
he's met he's one of the few characters
to be reunited with his family again so
he's got sons on stun side and she's
pretty powerful now and she can maybe do
something like legitimize him and he is
like we said King in the north
he's got experience with the White
Walkers now he's in a good place
this is like a triumphant kind of like
second wind for Jon Snow away he's where
he's the master of his own destiny which
I really appreciate I enjoyed seeing
that
so my final moment mm-hmm is we get to
see we got to see look how the White
Walkers were created I'm a big fan of
law origins though origin story this is
the most anime moment of the series so
far we tell people maybe because we've
not six seasons we've had now yeah five
seasons sorry and we've had very little
information about the White Walkers
right yeah there is almost nothing but
then it's the same with like the the
wood people what they called the forest
the water wood the wood forward that's
what I call them you're just messing up
all the log like we got to see it we
learn a little more about them as well
so they created the White Walkers so
they were created as a defense against
mankind the first men who are coming to
them and in eventually it was like you
know Terminator [ __ ] happened and they
were like actually we can be our own
people and they turned around and become
this unstoppable force
it's just slowly careening towards
Westeros now so basically what you're
saying is the White Walkers are Cylons
exactly
yeah the Cylons then you know
determinate is basically and I'm a big
fan of Cylons and terminators yeah you
know who's messing up the laws
all right Dave what about you my
favorite moment was probably one of the
more morbid ones it was the death of
ramsey himself
Ramsey Lamar that was a death like I
think we've all been waiting for for a
number of seasons now yeah I'm sad he's
gone you know well who are we gonna
direct our hate towards now like he was
really the hate magnet who were gonna
direct of attraction towards well we're
tasting like Game of Thrones characters
he's hot mega Reaper and like everything
wrong about this never reads have a talk
later on right we'll have an
intervention layer once reorder to this
like we'll go and talk about yeah that
big problem but his death the the
beautiful irony of this monster being
killed by his own hounds hmm amazing
like there was no CGI budget left for
ghosts
so it had to be his own hands well I was
I was talking to you before and I
thought that there's kind of a horrific
symmetry to it hmm so the first time we
see him truly become like the when it
becomes the Lord of Winterfell its many
stabs his father and kills his father
everyone knows that Ram but Roose Bolton
got poisoned okay
poisoned but that's poison there the
night the blade have died of bleeding
poison I've got too much steel in me
this is suspicious-looking dog in the
background like I was a secret all along
so hit him killing his father sees his
power and then he lures that is his
father's wife and his her newborn fat
Waldo to the kennels and then sets his
dogs on like a newly born child
literally rip yeah and literally just
destroyed a poor woman and her newborn
and then we see Sansa and if the
theory's are to be believed she is also
with child so it's it's Ramsay setting
dogs on a pregnant on a on a mother and
child and it ends with the mother and
child setting the dogs on him beautiful
it's also kind of a lot of horrific
there's a sighs faction like obviously
basketball happened but he's always been
the
kind of like I'm the best bastard like
look how successful I am and then John
snow comes back and it's like actually I
think you'll find I'm number one bastard
so it's like you get a satisfaction of
seeing these two bastards face off and
the better of them they're like the more
morally uncorruptible of them come out
on top which I appreciate is that really
felt like a like a good and evil fight
mmm
that was like the the clearest the lines
have been drawn with one guy is
unequivocally good and here the guy is
like pure unadulterated evil and then we
get to see like one of the most horrific
deaths of a show and its entirety
crunching also Jon Snow punched him a
whole bunch of times and yeah it was 21
or 22 something like that and each punch
was like for us that wasn't for like
there was no cinematography purpose
behind it was just for you guys just
watch this guy get punched over and over
again
speaking of that punch there's the the
intro to that leads me on to my second
favorite moment which is the
introduction of Lyanna Mormont the tiny
bear Lord Lady of the Bear Island like
we are a big fan of sass yeah and we're
a big fan of badass characters you know
and she is both and like a third of our
age yeah oh she's so like if I could
have been like like that when I was a
kid never been bullied or like just
sitting my forty-something Madden
everyone was it known like 66 - yes
something like that and she was just and
she was like yeah but we know that we're
gonna yeah well that was the thing like
they the Davos John and Santa had to
work for those men and they had to take
the field of abuse for those men this
smack she lays down on Sansa and she's
like what are you a stark oh you were
Bolton or you're a Lannister are you a
little finger why are you and now she
considers
snow a stark but it more than she answer
but the connection I was mentioning
isn't it she she gave like a poultry
number of men but was like no no
badasses though and then you see just as
John is running my Ramsay he uses one of
the moments shields to block the arrows
so you know that at least one of those
moments got to the gates of vision
she's got confidence like already and
she's like what ten years old she turned
the opinions of like all the lords of
the north by shaming yeah putting the
smack down a log love it like listen you
punk I love that Howard I love that she
was on the battlefield as well yeah yeah
I could just making sure everything
wonder why she was like during the whole
crunching scene because she she should
it wasn't in that she was like hide in
the trees like pretended to be one of
the guys a little finger does just
charge in the North remembers we know no
king but the king in the North whose
name is stark I don't care if he's a
busted that starts blood runs through
his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day and then I can't I don't think
we can mention things we loved without
the love that we all want to happen
Giants Bay the moment that those two met
eyes and tomans I is disrupted felt like
the moment is i bad game if I like the
moment the mask whether it was George
Rogers head but like in a game of
Thrones sense and then over like the
course of episodes we just see him like
sneaking looks it wasn't even just
sneaking looks he'd be like raising his
eyebrows like and then like seductively
ate in a chicken like that like he never
supposed to do it sort of barely he kind
of breathed in a direction from across
the table like in another chicken leg we
know how much the community loves this
this little relationship and how much
they when it's happened you just don't
know you have to look at the number of
memes and photo shops of the two
together and you know like I hope this I
think I think it's cuz its
it's really loved because it was so
unexpected because they've spent all
this time building up torment as this
you know this fearsome warrior that what
did he like kill a bear or something he
did something bad to a bear and like
he's like this very he's the most
wildling there is right he's got a giant
beard he yeah he's peak wall and covered
in first carries a massive weapon and
you know he's all like rough and rugged
and then sees like this lady is like hey
how's it going and it comes like a
little teenager and in a universe where
you know people are lusting after like
characters like Melisandre and yeah and
all the lovely ladies of King's Landing
yeah and then torrents like and there's
like a Jarman innocence to the way they
do it right you get different types of
approaching like love interest in this
in this series you get like Littlefinger
who's like mega creepy about yeah I know
some people like a bad boy I think
you're taking it too you know weird like
Ben Linus was also my favorite character
one loss I'm sensing or we had to even
old people so like you have those ones
and you have people are like aggressive
like weird rapey and then people like
Carl Drago is just like subjugation
but his one's like a really innocent
like almost like childlike like
schoolboy style flow I'm just gonna
start pulling a picture he doesn't know
how to flip probably frying a tennis
ball error and stuff hello cute ones
away yeah it's made to go my highlight
was probably Circe's slow but certain
descent into full-on mad queen
especially because it got seeded
throughout pretty much the whole season
cuz the end of season five Circe's
obviously you know she's down Beach it's
just Anna and a kid walk and she's
feeling pretty sorry for herself but
then like throughout the whole season
you get to see like when she has those
conversations with Qyburn like the
whispered conversations about the rumors
and then not just a great Fleetwood Mac
album the rumors with Qyburn and then
Qyburn getting all the little the little
to kind of do that and then we also see
with brands visions we also see like all
the wildfire so it's nice that it kind
of all comes together and then just the
way that scene was shot like the opening
of season of episode 10 with that piece
of music as well which I've pretty much
been listening to non-stop hmm it's
called like the Lord ally I think or
like the Seven what's great about the
music is I commented we're watching it
like it made me feel uncomfortable
yeah like then you realize by design I
wash it back and replace it with dubstep
but no I thought I was amazing and just
the way that that the way that morning
as well everyone's like Oh where's
Cersei she can't possibly miss it yeah
and then you just know something's up
and you know the way that the little
birds she's conveniently placed the way
that Lance all gets what's coming to him
gets shanked no I really loved she was
wearing pretty much the same outfit as
Tywin was when he was briefly king there
is a really great lease with the costume
director who said that was basically
that big and it looked it looked very
something I was like just like your
crazy ass dad I just got the Michael
Jackson outfit vibes also it's just sort
of like we always take the piss out of
associate because all of her Harebrained
Schemes basically don't really work but
this one she's actually thought out
really well like she goaded the Tyrells
into joining forces and working together
so all the Tyrells were there for
Marjorie and lorises well they rescued
Marjorie from her own like yeah of shame
right and then she'd go did them into
working together but Olenna pissed off
because she knew something wasn't quite
right yeah so she got rid of basically
all of her enemies in one fell swoop
apart from Dawn but everyone forgot they
existed anyway it's like we said last
week right it's hard to fail when your
option is a nuclear weapon basically
yeah she got rid of everyone she's in
charge she's got the mountains got kite
prime ends now
kind of Chanukah another he's wearing
the it's got a little pin yeah but I'm
but Tyrians going so I'm hoping that
when they meet they just like fight him
like their little figures like I've been
at the moment I really really enjoyed
was the tower of joy because what I just
I needed that resolution I was kind of
pissed that it took them like the entire
season like they went to the Tower of
joy in very early in the sea like
episode 2 and then like I get like a
foot closer to the amazing if they just
went full-on with it like open the door
and episode 1 and then episode 2 just
like the end of the seasons walk for a
mean like like 20 frames a reson the
evil door opening animation over the
course of 20 episodes I'm serious no but
I'm just glad that they finally finally
open the door
we've got they promise me Ned you've got
the you know got the resolution that
that very serious-looking baby would
turn into a very serious-looking young
man and obviously the lost off that may
or may not pay off yes II did more fan
theories about like the blood oh yeah
the stuff before II as well like the
battle leading up to it oh yeah you know
you seeing young Ned whoever they that
dude that they cost as young Ned well
done he looks like a young Neil Patrick
Harris yeah with an incredible Sean Bean
impression yeah I was a great casting
and obviously the the battle with his
buddy you know the legend that they had
yeah yeah that was those interesting as
well but yeah it did take a long time to
pay off but it was always gonna take a
long time right that was literally the
most important thing that they had to
reveal this season and if they did it
early on a beat a very it peak too high
too early and there'll be it I never
thought I'd say this but my other
favorite moment also involved bran which
is you know like branded like a 180 in
our hearts
of course of ten episodes which was the
whole door because I just thought that
was it was incredibly sad yeah but it
was so well done and just like the guys
named Sam Coleman he did an incredible
job of like just that really
heartbreaking moment with the whole dad
or I liked that moment it's very sad it
was touching
but like Brian continues to be an
annoying useless little mmm yeah Brian
keeps making so many mistakes earning
something every time he does it I'm like
Hodor sacrificed himself for you and
you're laying him down and like I would
rather have Hodor has been more
effective than bran and brands got this
like destiny to be the three-eyed Raven
his magical warg and [ __ ] but like
holo has been way more effective than
you he's done way more like get rid of
you should make him the three-eyed Raven
instead he'd be badass the worst part
about that saying is that I can no
longer ask someone to hold the door and
I live
moving on then so we had the dizzying
highs crushing lows tedious bit kind of
fillory lows time which was your least
favorite bit so my main I hated so I
ranked this I hated disliked and hated
yeah dawn everything in Dorne sand
snakes don't disappoint me yeah I mean
I've not read the books so I don't know
if I mean you've said before that the
sand snakes are a little cooler in the
books yes and they are they seem like
they have their potential to be about us
in the show as well but they just
there's something about them when
they're together they just did their
bats it's just so annoying like the
wasted potential part that you mentioned
they faked had the potential to be super
cool and there was that a whole bit
where one of them decided to just show a
boob and they had a relationship right
for like one episode they were and I am
and then bran just like I feel like the
writers were like oh no people like bran
get him out yeah the annoying thing is
that what they what they achieved or
what they did was actually quite
important to the overall story right so
they they got rid of Prince Doran and
you're not supposed to you they're not
supposed to but like within this kind of
architecture of this narrative within
within the TV series it's important
because they've effectively aligned
themselves with the Tyrells against the
Lannisters and the Lannisters are now in
fact but they did it at the very start
of the season so no one remembers
anything that happened until the very
end in the book they did that and Doran
was alive it was like dog
Doronin been a Targaryen loyalists for
years and he couldn't let them all burn
and what always Durin's purpose I don't
know like he literally did nothing he
was they was like I'm well sick my
brothers well dead he's mental and then
he go gang yeah and that was it and the
other thing is like dawn as a place it
was quite disappointing it was at every
major city in the series so far is they
spend the time to give it an identity
right and they give it like a little
time to present it and give it a
personality as a place like you have
King's Landing being opulent place and
when I fell being this really cool dawn
is like as far as we know it's hot and
yellow we know is that one palace and
there are no citizens like spend some
time just we know there's sand outside
somewhere there were no thing about the
motivations of the bike a lot of the
motivations of the people of the
characters within major places within
the cities can be seen in like the
people right and how they you know how
they loved or disliked among the people
is important to the story whereas we've
gone you've got none of that you're like
honey everyone loves everyone in Dorne
except the sand snakes you hate everyone
it's just so weird like and obviously we
had Oberyn wasn't the best part of dawn
like and he was and we barely saw him
there he was just a representative and
he was a badass and even he screwed up
like an idiot confirm your kills god
damn it cook event I do agree with a lot
of the points you you made the biggest
thing that kind of irked me though is
how Tyrion kind of just didn't matter
like is in everything he did just kind
of got reset when Danny turned up yeah I
think I found about Tyrion is that like
they put him in marine so he can be with
Daenerys when she decides to come over
and he's got his pivotal role there but
they still need to justify Peter
Dinklage being the top billing and the
cast yeah so like every episode they'll
give him like a little speech or a fun
story that doesn't add anything to the
plot or just like an awkward encounter
with grey worm and Miss Sunday
why don't we tell some jokes that was so
all I know and he and he started a joke
and never finished it yeah that's my
biggest season except ridiculous seasons
like please finish your joke period and
when they were when the sun's the harpy
would being a real pain in the ass
they're like okay let's kill him no no
we got it we got a secure peace yeah
they secure like a really you know
awkward fragile peace and they turned up
procedure City and then it's like to
kill to me that one duck yeah so like
none of his actions really made a
difference
they said he said like varus disappears
and gets you know dawn on side so he
really did more tumors like just he was
basically just he was the guy that you
send in to keep the plants watered and
the pets fed when you go on holiday here
and then he comes back his like yeah
it's right like you know plans a bit
will tea I saw that hey breathe some
life back into the city right that's the
one lasting impression that he left all
of his of his presence there so like he
got because by the end of the season
like the markets were bustling again and
people wow and about yeah thing that
actually annoyed me because we expected
at least I expected the red precess to
be a big plot point because she was she
was given time in the entire season six
trader were like are cool the second mad
woman
then she was like yeah I'll talk about
Danny and then leaves and then we never
see anything again we just see people
being like Danny is spot on me up some
flags
sell sell your eggplants and vegetables
don't kill each other and then eight and
then Sons the happy actually do come
back anyway so again it's just another
inconsequential moment yeah also the
fact that they had to start to ship
Misun day and grey worm just to make
those characters interesting just to
give Kapil beforehand right like they
were doing the berry in season five yes
he was looking at having a wash
yeah that counts for me that's enough of
me be I didn't really like his season
was like just how I is storyline in
Braavos culminated I thought it was a
bit disappointing
I guess because like
you you see her getting whacked by the
by the wave like week in week out you
see the wave just completely kicking her
ass and then she does her weird out of
character thing that I don't I'm not
entirely convinced the way for the
Fallen for because she's so out there
with it and she's you know slamming
money down being really obvious walking
around you know I don't think the wife
is that stupid but then so when you get
to that final confrontation scene where
she's like you know she cuts the candle
we as the viewer don't get the
satisfaction of watching the wife die we
just can't see her face with the eyes
gouged out put in the Hall of faces that
annoyed me and also just the way that
she's sort of you know like Jack him
brought her to the house of black and
white and trained her and you know try
to make her know one and then he finally
says you are no one and she goes alright
peace out that's it you know show you
absolutely nothing by and just leaves
and jet packs away again I mean we've
spoken before about how I'm gonna come
out and say how bad the part of the
passage of time is yeah in this season I
think I err Yara and Dion and
particularly virus or ones that have
really suffered from that just because
it's so a lot of people a lot of people
mentioned you know obviously there is
time passing in between these but I mean
there's ways of showing that and this
season the show has made no attempt of
doing that like for anyone
most people will will see these things
before you know most people won't pay
too much mind to it but for people who
are is does come off as feeling a bit
inconsistent a bit weird with the
passage of time and it at the same time
and stuff like flashbacks and time
traveling all this other crazy stuff
happening you're like what is it's kind
of like excuse your perspective of time
I think it's something that we bring up
a lot and a lot of people are like come
on guys but like it's it's an important
thing right yeah it took us a like
segwaying a bit from the area thing but
when we saw various it took us out of
the moment so so much that we were like
is your faceless man that yes he's
traveled real fun real fast
yeah no then we just worked out that
yeah I mean thing about August thing as
well is that we spend however long in
the house of black and white and we're
still no closer to really understand
how the faceless mine thing work yeah
face often just pull a face off what do
you need to get one from the war because
then how would you take that to Westeros
because like would it not need to keep
moisturized in a bag or something just a
sip lock bag full of like formaldehyde I
got one I've just realized you guys seen
face off what if he was Joe is a
faceless man I have to go guys
there's a threat I need to write Oh to
read it
have fun fix it well it's been a good
ten weeks we've been prattling on about
Game of Thrones so sadly GameSpot of
Thrones there won't be any weekly
episodes anymore because what we're
gonna talk about you know but every
trade find something to be honest I will
just talk about my little finger fanfic
but until season 7 starts you know if
there's ever any whisper of news if
George decides to release the book but
you might not do - probably not too busy
rolling around in money yeah oh if you
know new trailers special editions of
the blu-rays as well some interesting
behind-the-scenes tidbits we will be
there I'll be jumping on it but thank
you so much for joining us all this time
and listening to us pray lon it's been a
real fun show to do mmm so in the
meantime you can find us all on Twitter
I'm out tomorrow H I'm at a regular date
nobody's James games thank you for
watching and we will see you next time
you